uh we've got a lot of leftism in in our
culture right now
and we've got a lot of grading on a
curve and all the rest of it the Buffalo
Bills cut punter Matt arraza has been
booted out of football and why is that
because of an allegation surfacing that
he participated in a gang rape of a
minor okay and this really ties in with
what we've been saying about the
disfavored groups here in our culture
the accusation is that he participated
in the gang rape of a minor while he
attended San Diego State University the
accuser filed a civil lawsuit against
reyez and three other men including two
former SDSU teammates then prosecutors
in San Diego's DA's office declined to
file criminal charges why why do they
decline to file charges because the guy
wasn't even there at the time
he couldn't have committed this crime he
wasn't even in the building at the time
according to Yahoo DA's office concluded
a raise it couldn't couldn't have led
the girl into the alleged gang rape
because he had left the home at about 12
30 a.m an hour prior to when evidence
suggested the alleged gang rape would
have occurred he wasn't even at the
party any more the DA's office says that
this girl did appear to have sexual
contact with a bunch of guys at this
party but that none of it appears to
indicate rape and in fact some of it was
caught on camera because we're being
surveilled 24 7 and it shows that her
story was
not true but this guy this football
player was already tried in the media
and his life is already ruined his
career is already ruined and that's that
and there are many many such cases
now one conclusion from this is
obviously people should have due process
we shouldn't have people tried for very
serious Crimes by Committees of of
professors or by hack journalists or
anybody else there's another side to
this story though which is
was co-education a mistake
I'm not saying in all cases I'm not
saying but right now we have an
educational system that does not
distinguish really in any way between
men and women including in dormitories
including in Suites in dormitories there
will be gender neutral Suites so you're
sharing a room with men and women you're
sharing a bathroom that's been going on
for 10 years that was true when I was in
college
and obviously you're sharing dormitories
and is that
is that smart
I don't know if you put people who are
just brimming bags of hormones and then
you apply them with alcohol which is
what happens at every single college
campus and then the the lines of of
consent get a little bit blurry when
people can are no longer in command of
their rational faculties and so all of a
sudden you've got cases of regret which
then seem to be rape or one can make a
claim of rape even though
investigations and even surveillance
footage will show it it wasn't actually
a rape but was this
if we're talking about how the law is a
teacher and culture can be Downstream of
the law
wouldn't it make sense to just draw some
of these distinctions a little bit more
recognize that women are in fact the
weaker sex men ought to be chivalrous
when you put young men and women
together in certain situations and
they're there all the time and they're
drinking a lot and their things can
happen that are not conducive to their
virtue
we talk about how we don't know the
difference between men and women anymore
because of the transgender issue
these issues started way before that and
so if men and women really are different
shouldn't we acknowledge that in all
sorts of places in our law right now go
to carzing.com Knowles buying a new car
can be a stressful experience for anyone
especially if you're a first-time buyer
or have no credit before you walk into a
dealership and spend the whole day with
the crowds and the stress and the
potential not even to find a car you
need to check out carsing carsing is
completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and over 25
000 dealers Nationwide karzing provides
you with everything you need before
stepping foot into a dealership you can
instantly pre-qualify online without
affecting your credit score and get
instant financing details including what
your down payment would be your monthly
payment term APR putting you several
steps ahead of other buyers once you
find the right car at your ideal budget
all you've got to do is bring your saved
deal voucher with you to the dealership
finalize your next ride it is so simple
people even if you're not in the market
for a new car you should check out
carsing anyway it's like window shopping
just poke around you see what's
available in your area carsync helps
make your experience faster cheaper less
stressful go to carson.com Knowles skip
all that guesswork carzing.com Knowles I
have just read the most nauseating
article
that I've read in in a long time I don't
have a waste paper basket or anything
near me so I'm going to try to keep it
together as I pull this out for the show
it is
an article by Wired Magazine this very
lengthy article profile
of Pete bootage
there he is Mayor Pete looking so he's
looking cool
he's looking so hip it says Pete bootage
Edge loves God beer and his electric
Mustang
sure the U.S Secretary of Transportation
has thoughts on Building Bridges but
infrastructure occupies just a sliver of
his voluminous mind
oh I'm getting a I'm getting a tingle up
my leg
a thrill
here's what they're saying I I encourage
you to read the whole profile it is
don't do it after you've just had a big
lunch I mean I would recommend you do it
on an empty stomach so this is how the
whole thing opens
the Curious mind of Pete bootage Edge
holds much of its functionality and
Reserve even as he discusses railroads
derailing no they don't talk about
derailing railroads and Airlines down to
the pointless data that is his current
stock and trade the U.S Secretary of
Transportation comes off like a Mensa
black card holder who might have a
secret go habit that's a game that
mostly Asian people play or a
three-second Rubik's Cube solution or a
knack for supplying off the top of his
head the day of the week for a random
date in 1404 along with a
non-condescending history of the Julian
and Gregorian calendars that's how the
piece begins
and it only gets crazier from there but
this is my favorite one
it's my favorite piece
I slowly became aware that his cabinet
job requires only a modest portion of
his cognitive Powers other mental
faculty other mental facilities no
kidding are apportioned to The Iliad
Puritan historiography and nascarred
spring they're not in the original
Norwegian slacker
fortunately he was willing to devote yet
another apps in his Cathedral mind to
making his ideas about three Mighty
themes neoliberalism masculinity and
Christianity intelligible to me I'm not
going to talk about Buddha judge I'm not
going to diminish his uh
cathedral-like mind it's
to me the most distressing part of this
article is not what it says about our
absolute failure of a transportation
secretary it's like the easiest job in
any Administration and this guy has
somehow managed to screw it up by not
showing up for work and not fixing the
problems he was supposed to fix and
focusing on racist Bridges instead of
keeping our railroads secure so that
trains can move on them but I'm going to
put that aside for a second the thing
that was most shocking to me here
was that this wired writer is impressed
that a member of the president's cabinet
has read The Iliad
how far has our culture Fallen that that
is now the sign of having gone above and
beyond in one scholarly Pursuits The
Iliad if we lived in a normal culture
every high school student would have
read The Iliad
now you need to be a Rhodes scholar
working directly for the president of
the United States to have read one of
the foundational works of Western
literature that basically reads like a
Marvel movie it's not even like like The
Iliad is some really abstruse philosophy
The Iliad is a war story and poem that's
really fun and exciting we are so
uncultured we are so ignorant we are so
male educated today that that is
impressive that a columnist that a
profile writer a journalist in Wired
Magazine says other mental facilities no
kidding are apportioned to The Iliad no
kidding yeah I hope
I hope the people running our government
have read like even the basic works of
our civilization ah these low
expectations
it's a failure of journalistic Integrity
of course but it's just pathetically low
expectations how long are we supposed to
continue as a republic if we live like
this if we don't know a damn thing about
anything and we're impressed when our
leaders can read
not
not a good sign
boy what a clip that was huh if you want
to get more of them as well as the long
interviews and the full show and all the
different games you gotta ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel